la mine des mauvais jours embourbé
depuis deux semaines dans des combats
avec des groupes armés colombien le
venezuela en appel par le biais de son
président nicolas sma d'euros au soutien
urgent des nations unies dans le but de
procéder à des opérations de déminage
profession que son fils y ait de la
république bolivarienne du venezuela le
professeur aurait arrêt asa est en train
d'envoyer une communication secrétaire
général des nations unies antonio
guterres est pour demander une aide
d'urgence immédiate du système des
nations unies afin d'apporter toutes les
technologies nécessaires pour désactiver
les champs de mines laissées par ces
groupes illégaux d'assassins et de
trafiquants de drogue colombiens un
appel solennel
alors que les relations entre caracas et
le nude temps à se réchauffer ces
dernières années une demande qui
illustre également la marge de manoeuvre
réduite dont dispose le pouvoir
vénézuélien les combats impliquerait des
dissidents présumés des ex forces armées
révolutionnaires colombiennes
officiellement inactive depuis l'accord
de paix conclu en 2016 entre bogota et
la guérilla accord que rejette ces
groupes des combattants dont maduro
dresse un portrait au vitriol entre dans
la pratique à la mine antipersonnel
katsina ils ont introduit au venezuela
la pratique de la pose de mines
pratiques meurtrières des groupes armés
cooling nous avons perdu plusieurs
soldats vénézuéliens à cause des mines
et des meurtriers en thaïlande et aux
chaussures
ils ont apporté les méthodes salle est
répugnant que de la guerre colombiennes
au venezuela et je les condamne ces
violences à la frontière entre les deux
états sud-américains oblige de nombreux
vénézuéliens à fuir il serait déjà
plusieurs milliers à avoir traversé la
frontière pour se réfugier côté
colombien
à en croire bogota